i am thrilled uh about our next guest i
am such a fan of his work you know we've
had paul rudd on this program
uh so much talking about fantasy
football he's in a fantasy league with
him
along with the rest of the characters
from the marvel cinematic universe
loved him in eight mile loved him in the
hurt locker and now he's on
netflix's outside the wire he's a
die-hard saints fan from
the great city of new orleans he is none
other than anthony mackie how are you
anthony
hey what's up good to chat with you
how's everything
uh everything is good man just loving my
city hanging out
okay are you in new orleans right now is
that where you are i am i am in new
orleans proper yes sir
okay is this where you were on sunday
anthony
sunday i was in atlanta because if we
pulled off a miracle and one
i wanted to flaunt it
[Laughter]
which kind of brings me to my uh first
question for you anthony is that
how do you view it with a sense of irony
or sense of um
something else that you as a die-hard um
saint fan is known in the marvel
cinematic universe is falcon
it's very annoying uh that's why i've
tried to have the character name changed
several times
i've and i've referred to him as sam not
the falcon
understood okay you know it's just
something that i have to do
because uh i got to tell you i know this
firsthand having been around uh
great saints fans and also uh in the
super bowl in atlanta where the rams
made it because of the whole past
interference thing
is that is that falcons fans uh who are
all over town
were were very pleased that the saints
did not make it to that super bowl
that year anthony and they were
vocalizing that quite a bit oh yeah
definitely and it had to be
because the last thing they wanted was
their inaugural super bowl to be won by
the saints because everybody knew
the saints was going to win that game
and if you look at the play that the
referee
didn't call how do you not make that
call that's a correct that is a correct
assessment we're still wondering how
that happened
there you go so i could only that would
never happen to brett favre
that would never happen aaron rodgers
that would never happen to tom brady
only to agree
oh my gosh um do you do you think this
is it for drew
anthony it sure looked like it to me
what do you think i hope so
uh i i hope so i think drew gave it his
all i think
um i think um sean proved
sunday that he would rather lose
withdrew
than win with james winston and that was
mind-blowing to me that game really
just pushed the entire city over the
edge with the drew shawn love affair
because you have desean watson sitting
out there and he's
five hours away and i will drive to his
house
put him in my truck let him live in my
house and make
him breakfast if he were to come to the
site every day
just breakfast anthony just one meal a
day that's it that's all you're making
breakfast
i'm not i'm not going to be his personal
chef i just want to make sure he wakes
up
you'd have company though i think
everybody's willing to drive even if
it's not just five hours away to go get
deshaun watson and bring him to their
head oh yeah
but think about desean watson with alvin
kamara michael thomas
and we get a great tight end out of the
draft on in
sean payton's system think about that
think about desean watson
in sean payton's system that's drew
brees but
a mobile drew brees who could actually
run and move around
with alvin kamara coming out in the flat
with michael thomas in the slot
who can catch everything yeah but you
might have to
uh ask the uh pelicans to straight zion
to the rockets to make it work because i
don't know
what uh what the saints could also would
give up to go get him
this might have to be a two-league trade
anthony first
first round pick everything we give we
give them all
who are you going to get out of the
draft that's going to play better than
desean watson
everybody talk about these quarterbacks
coming out the draft but nobody's proven
that that kid from clemson never played
against the nfl linebacker
you're referring to you're talking about
trevor lawrence is who he referred to
anthony
yeah trevor lawrence never saw six foot
two
225 pounds of pure chocolate coming out
here
[Laughter]
yes you're you're correct he's probably
never seen that sort of thing but uh
exactly and if you think about college
ball there are only
two maybe three great players on each
team when you're in a pros
every player is a great player
so let's put outside of you you not
being able or your team being able to
pull this off
taysom hill or jameis what do you think
about the next quarterback there
if you had a chance uh it has to be
jamie
yeah i didn't call he didn't do that
during the season though i mean
it when it he went taste some hill
instead so you don't you're you're not a
taste some guy or you're a james
i mean walk me through your your mindset
here anthony
well we through that taste them pay for
missing the quarterback
okay jason isn't a quarterback he's more
of a a gimmick um
a gimmick uh like role player i feel
like if you look at jameis
james jameis has the wheels that he can
still move around
jameis can he he showed uh sunday
with that 60-yard rope that he threw
down the field
that he has the arm and the ability to
get the ball down the field
and he wasn't the problem in tampa bay
you have wirelessly you had an
undisciplined team you had a wide
receivers running
routes they wanted to run you had an
offensive line that wouldn't block form
you i mean you can't say that he was the
problem in tampa bay
anthony mackey here on the rich eisen
show uh outside the wire on netflix i
want to get to that in a second but i do
want to ask you
a couple other uh part parts of your
your filmography and your your history
um eight mile uh what's your favorite
eminem story
from favorite marshall mathers story
from that set
[Laughter]
there was uh there was this one day
we're sitting on set
and uh eminem comes over and he's like
yo what's up man
i was like hey what up em so he's like
cool cool so
you know i was reading the script and i
was kind of thinking
like there's no reason for me not to
like you like you're a cool dude
like i like you i was like i like you
too he's like cool so you don't mind if
i like add some stuff in a trip
about you i was like well
about me or about the character he's
like no no just add some stuff in the
script like you know just side character
stuff
i'm like yeah no problem so
he goes and his entire battle the final
rap
he googles me and like learns about me
and all this stuff
and he basically like makes fun of me
as papa doc
and i'm like well that's a little too
personal there uh mr marshall
[Laughter]
and it's stuck in the movie it stuck
yeah his whole final battle i'm like
yeah well yeah i mean yeah i grew up in
a nice house and
yeah my parents they were nice to me why
why are you poking fun
[Laughter]
so what happened when uh when when when
a cut got called what happened
what happened he just he literally
walked over and was like yo that's gonna
be dope
yeah that's gonna be great for you
i'm happy for you i'll just stand over
here with the look and
let that pass and so your reaction on
camera
was that your first initial reaction
that was kept as well
enabled yeah yeah there was not no
i mean what else so i go to curtis and
i'm like yo curtis what would be good
is if he do his rap then i do a rap and
it's a tie and then he does another rap
and i don't say nothing i was like but i
gotta say something
he's like no no i think it'll work
better people say that you don't say
anything
like so i don't get to say nothing i get
no nothing i just stand there he's like
yep
oh boy okay oh man i did not know that
that is amazing yeah it was pretty
you're the first person i've told that
story
i did not i will take that exclusive and
run with it because that is
that is amazing that gives me a whole
new person like now i want to go see it
again
you know now i want to see it none of
that stuff was in the movie because they
were developing my character as the
movie went on
so curtis will come to me every day and
be like well what do you think about
this so because we had developed a
friendship over the course of shooting
because i loved his work so much
right he was like well what do you think
about this for your character what do
you think about that i was like oh okay
so all those extra themes we put in
there
i actually got to spend a lot of time
with uh eminem and we became cool
you know and he was like well there's no
reason for me not
like with boys like onset offset why
why don't i like you i'm a good point
so that's when he just proceeded to
murder me so did you really go to
cranbrook
[Laughter]
no but i did go to private school
i went to north carolina school of the
arts
oh my gosh that's a first fantastic
i went to north carolina school of the
arts for high school which is great i
mean you should be commended for that
you know what i mean like that's what i
said not bullied by some
young rapper anthony mackey here
on the rich eisen show what did what
appealed to you uh
about outside the wire anthony obviously
you've been in some big time
uh films big budget big action you've
been
in something that could be considered
science fiction as well what what a pre
what did you like about outside the wire
anthony you know what from the first
time i read it um
growing up in this business well growing
up as an actor there are certain actors
that i idolized that i just
always wanted to be like when i grew up
in wesley snipes was a big part
of me growing up and wanting to be an
actor so i always wanted to do like a
wesley snipes movie
so when i read this script it really hit
me is
terminator meets training day and um
when i put those two movies together i
was like holy those are two amazing
moves
if i could do those together i'm in that
all day
so we uh our biggest our biggest
uh problem or the hardest point with
this movie
was finding the other actor and
once i found dancing i knew we had
something special i knew
his energy with mine would be a perfect
fit for the training day storyline
so um you know i just i i love old
school
hollywood popcorn action movies
i love passenger 57 like i love
independence day
i love those movies so for me it was an
opportunity to do one of those types of
movies
and you're referring to dance and idris
who's in the film michael kelly as well
by the way
he's a falcon fan i don't know if that
was discussed on the set i know you're
not i know
i believe i've known michael kelly for
almost 25 years
and literally we uh we've got we've gone
at it many times
about uh about our our alliance to our
team that's amazing i mean that is a
great rivalry no doubt about that uh the
falcon
and winter soldier premiering in march
on disney plus
uh my kids are fired up about this what
should i tell them about this
uh this show that's coming up anthony
it's
it's it's a it's a really good show i
was worried when we
when i first heard it was streaming that
the quality would be lost
that you know it would just turn into
this idea of what
these movies could be and they wouldn't
be able to do the action sequences
and give us the look that we've come
accustomed to with marvel movies
but the action sequences are
mind-blowing the story is great you
really get to know the characters and
fall in love with the characters as you
can see with one division
and it just it just brings you further
into the universe
so it's um it's it's it's not going to
disappoint i'm very excited for people
to see it
yeah i mean my my kids uh saw end game
before i did and totally spoiled it uh
i'll be very honest with you
that actually happened and i'm like g
are you kidding me you know uh
you know i they saw it before me so are
you going to be the next captain america
well see that's the thing at the end of
end game
sam didn't accept the shield if you
remember he told steve
it doesn't feel right because this
shield is yours right
so you know the the show is a a long way
of figuring around
who's going to be captain america who
where's the shield going to end up
and if captain america if that moniker
is going to
come back and you know somebody's going
to hold that down moniker again
okay and so uh i guess last one for you
on this at least did you did you beat
the
uh previous captain america in a fantasy
league did you at least take out
chris evans how did this work walk me
through this
i didn't so i was in europe shooting
falcon winter soldier when we had our
draft okay
so i'm on set it's like 3 a.m
so i missed the first like three or four
rounds of the draft
and literally everybody who i got auto
given
got hurt the first two weeks of the
season
so saquon is that saquon
yep was my first round pick out
going boom just like that so you so you
probably so you had the second overall
pick in this draft
pretty much i think that's probably what
third wow so
that's unfortunate that he dropped to
three for for that so who's in this
who's in this league it's it's it's from
the marvel universe right this league
yeah it's pretty much all marvel people
is
basically us raising money for our
charities of choice um
and this year we did it through
draftkings which was great um
it's pretty much like chris evans uh
pratt
uh rdj uh uh
don cheadle used to be in it but he's
you know
he's too busy for us now he just you
know
chimes in with very disparaging and rude
comments
rod i know rudd's in it i know paul's
yeah
and he's a seahawks fan right he's a
die-hard seahawks fan
yeah which is very annoying well i mean
rudd's team keeps on churning who do you
think's gonna win the super bowl anthony
mackie before i let you go
who do you think's gonna i'll say this
rich it was clear
yes with all this cte talk and
everything it was clear
that patrick mahomes had a concussion
when he was coming off that field yes
that was very clear he didn't lose his
breath he didn't know he he was
concussed he couldn't stand up so i'll
be interested to see
i think this game has to do this week
has to do with
who plays quarterback for kansas city
there's no way they're beating buffalo
buffalo's running on all cylinders
without patrick mahomes
he's the he's the twinkie in the box of
goodness
so the best super bowl would be uh
i think because kansas city doesn't have
that good of a defense i mean we almost
beat him
we lost about three and drew brees had
other than sunday the worst game of his
career
so i think buffalo
green bay would be the best super bowl
and i want my man i want my man aaron
rodgers to pull it out man that's my
dude
she said i'm always a cheese head second
raspberry i'm a cheese as second why is
that
because i was there when brett favre uh
beat new england in new orleans i was at
the super bowl
so i've i've grown up a lot of people in
new orleans having a
like an infinite love for green bay uh
mostly because brent farve is from
mississippi but because
they were the big team when we were all
growing up like even if you listen to
lil wayne he's a green bay fan
that's right so it was just a thing
about our generation and they won that
super bowl here which was an amazing
weekend
well anthony i i'm like i said i'm a big
fan of your work
um i i knew when you'd come on the show
uh it would be dynamite i'd love to keep
doing this i love chatting with you i
love your work and i
i will now i will now forever watch
eight mile
differently oh my god
oh my god get somebody to call desean
and tell him
i got some beignets and dagger is
waiting
done done anthony congrats on outside
the wire let's do this more often thanks
for the call
definitely thanks a lot guys that's
anthony mackey one and only
at anthony mackey on twitter and
instagram
being yay and daiquiris that's not a bad
fantasy team name too
in being every super bowl every morning
beignets and daiquiris beignet not a
daiquiri i mean rich you know watched
eight mile
20 30 times never knew that that's his
he went and he's like i'm gonna go
google and use that against you
and he had no idea and they're like
let's do it
that's amazing that's a wrap that's a
take that's it this guy's like
his real name is clarence that clarence
lives at home with both parents
i mean claire's parents have a really
good marriage like these guys
that come on i love it eight mile
amazing rich can i drop uh
just another eight mile little note
there sure i used to
i was friends with brittany murphy uh
the late britain she rest in peace yeah
and there were times you know we hung
out for a few years and and one time she
told me a story
that she had no idea how to throw up a
middle finger
because she never flipped anyone off in
her entire life until
she did eight mile and marshall eminem
had to sit her down and teach her how
to do it and if you watch the movie like
he has a weird way of flipping people
off and if you look she does it the
exact same way he does
and i was like how is it that you've
never flipped anyone off before my gosh
i gotta watch eight mile ago nice person
we're learning a lot of stuff
about eight months amazing and then just
again
uh tj jefferson the forest gump of the
rich eyes
yes literally has floated through life
and met
everybody tidbits with tj tidbits with
tj
hey everybody great job mike part of res
consulting
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here